[Music]
all right let's go to bridget in
baltimore
uh what's up bridget
hi how are you
i'm good how are you
pretty good good what's up
so i have an interesting question
so my stepson who's 20 moved back to the
baltimore area not too long ago and we
were getting our nails done one day with
my husband and him and
he
casually said oh by the way
i had a threesome with my
brother and his wife
and so my husband and i
don't know how to handle that
really
okay so i i
the whole picture here is fantastic
um and by fantastic i mean like highly
disturbing so you and how old are you
i'm 26.
this is even more fantastic how old's
your husband
he's 43. okay
and all right so
he has remarried somebody basically the
same age as his kids
yes and y'all all three three of you
were out getting manicures together
yes incredible and then
i say incredible i guess that's not
that's not a bad thing to eat your own
my dad's never taken me for a manicure i
may hit him up for one over the holidays
um so the three of y'all are out and
while you're getting your manicure
um your
stepson who's the same age as you
says it sounds like a country song um
your stepson is the same age as you
tells you and your husband
hey bt dubs
i had a threesome with my brother and
his wife
yes
was it just like a casual like hey by
the way um starbucks the the pumpkin
spice lattes are coming out earlier this
year oh and uh i mean it was it like
that was it like a big deal pretty much
he didn't i mean he didn't really think
anything of it he thinks it's totally
fine
all right so there's no way
i know i've met with some folks who have
some um very outside the bell curve
sexual preferences proclivities
nobody would think this is super normal
or super cool what was the follow-up
conversation like
there was nothing
so that's what i found upsetting is my
husband didn't really say anything about
it
because he he has pcsd from being in the
army and he says nothing really shocks
him so he didn't really find it that
all right so
not responding to that has nothing to do
with ptsd okay
it doesn't it's not like uh
nothing can shock you fine ptsd is a
diagnostic that's a whole other that's a
trauma response i i don't
that was just simply he either froze or
he doesn't care
but yeah that's not those are those i
would not conflate those two things so
let's say that like
how long have you all been married
uh five and a half years okay
um
so you how you were 21
yes
and you met this strapping 39 year old
how'd that how'd y'all meet
uh facebook
i love the internets of course you did
that's fantastic
wow okay so
what's your question how about that
let's start there
so my question is is i told my mom this
like because i was so shocked and i
didn't get a reaction to him and i was
kind of like how do i process it so i
called my mom why my mom was like why'd
you call your mom
you're a
you're like a grown married like why'd
you call your mom is she just like a
confidant for you yeah
oh okay
okay and so she said that
so
the plot twist of this is that he came
back to the area because there's a plot
twist
i thought this was most of the movie
let's plot twist go go for it
um it's that he is working for my
husband and i so that's why he came back
to the area okay so i was telling my mom
about the situation and she's like well
you should keep it just professional
because we were taking him out to eat
and trying to help him out i was going
above and beyond doing all kinds of
other stuff for him to help him out and
so my mom's like you should stop doing
that pretty much and take a step back
and just do business with him now
but my husband's like why should you
treat him any differently because
this was in the past and the reason why
he stopped doing this with his brother
and his wife was because he said he
wasn't attracted to his wife so he would
have kept doing it had he found her
attractive
but that means y'all had more than one
conversation about this
after that like this is like a few weeks
ago so i brought it up to him because i
was like i'm a little disturbed that
you're not saying anything about this
and i think you need to tell him that
it's not right
okay and what was the response there
he's like i told him but what you want
me to do cut him off just because
he did something like this and i was
like i don't know
okay
um you're the only person on the phone
with me
and so i am can only talk to you is that
cool
all right
so
um i am a
i don't say outside the box nothing like
your husband nothing surprised me
nothing shocks me anymore okay
um
and i am
almost universally very sympathetic to
situations people find themselves in
whether it's addiction whether it's
sexual like whatever wherever they find
themselves
um i always want to
sit down and offer some offer drink and
some nachos let's figure this out okay
um but nobody else is on the phone but
you and me so i will say
i will boldly state i'm going to go way
out on a line like on a on a thin line
here
and say
having sex with your brother
and your brother's spouse
is pretty screwed up
by any metric
it's um
it's
pretty distorted disturbing behavior
okay
but that goes way over here because
that's not the real issue here's the
real issue
you are an adult
five years into a marriage
and you are responding to those around
you like a child
you call your mommy for advice
you're talking to your husband as though
he's your dad
and you are bouncing your values and
your safety and your
business
off of um
you're not making decisions from a
value-based core
okay so the issue here is
yes that is outside the bell curve
that's way out there okay
um anybody listening to this very very
few people will experience their son
having sex with his brother and his wife
right very people
all of us will experience i don't want
to be around x y z i don't want to be
around certain behaviors i don't want to
work with certain behaviors i'm not
going to have employees that work for me
that act certain ways
and you have to decide what your values
are what you will and will not tolerate
and then you've got to make those
decisions based on your values
that make sense
yes and so let me ask you
do you want to do business with this
person because a you're disgusted by it
but b i can hear your voice you don't
trust this person
their wisdom their decision-making like
i can hear it in you
um
do you want to do business with this
person
[Music]
i mean if it's just business then he's
okay but personal life there's just a
bunch of crazy stuff that happens with
him that i don't want involved in and
that was my next step is this is one
isolated this is not one i said incident
let me say like that there's gonna be
other behavioral issues is that fair
way
more
okay
so
um
have you sat down and told your husband
i do not want to have meals with this
person i don't want this person in my
home
uh yes and he gets kind of like
defensive okay so there is a challenge
that you found yourself where you're
gonna end up pitting
you and your values versus your husband
and his kids
this is different when they're in home
at home right and this is a i'll tell
folks the opposite of them would tell
you when there are young children at
home
you can as a as a
stepmom if you will you can never pit
your
spouse against their kids
this in my mind is different because
this is y'all's home
right these are grown kids lived
somewhere else
and now they're circling back and this
is i think you've got every right to say
this is what i
um
need in this home or let me ask you
another question
if he lets this kid move in he's okay
he's falling on hard times he's moving
in are you gonna stay
uh we've already done that once
okay
and i mean so the question i mean he has
an apartment so that's not gonna happen
but oh
sweet bridgette it could happen any time
it can happen anytime anytime
let me so let's just call it like what
are your boundaries gonna be
is there ever a moment when you're gonna
leave
i don't
know
you do know because i have so many
people in my head telling me like oh
it's not wrong it is wrong i know it's
wrong but i don't know how to handle it
like where do i draw the line i know
what nobody thinks that's okay
nobody
nobody
you've had you've had friends and family
tell you dude it's just it's all good
it's cool
not exactly cool but
like everyone's like oh well
i did a facebook poll on it just out of
curiosity some people are like it's not
your business so stay out of it because
they're adults
hey you know what that's different
that's actually accurate it's their
business
but when it becomes your business is
when that sort of character that sort of
behavior that sort of lack of judgment
and wisdom comes into your home comes
into your business
so you can't make adults stop doing
behaviors
you can't the only person you can
control is you so a
never put family business in a facebook
poll good god bridgette don't ever do
that ever
two
that the advice you guys actually
correct
the question you have to ask yourself is
what are you going to do not what are
they going to do your husband can't stop
them your
his two sons from having sex together
yeah he can't
and having threesomes but you can't stop
that what he can stop is
i am not going to participate in that
world
and let's make it does that mean
does that mean he should just do
business or does that mean we should
just cut i don't do business with people
that i wouldn't share a meal with
okay i don't because business ult you
you can't bifurcate the business there's
a fantastic study and i remember driving
home with my eyes bugging out of my head
that this was a study and that
i was like
didn't we all know this but clearly we
didn't do you remember back in the day
uh you may be a bit young there was um
i think it was holly madison kelly
the website yeah it was a hal ashley
madison okay it was uh bridgette it was
a site called ashley madison and it was
a
uh do you remember that
no okay so it was a quote-unquote
anonymous site for married people to
have affairs with other married people
who are interested in it
and it was kind of like uh
tinder or
what it was like way upstream of those
um it was earlier on but it was you
could put in your email address and put
in your um credit card number and then
meet up with other married people in
your area
somebody leaked all of the email
addresses and there was a big technique
i like famous people and fancy pants
religious like people got busted okay
but a couple of social scientists did a
study they took the addresses
and went and thumbed through
companies and businesses in the u.s
and i'm gonna butcher the details a
little bit but the the findings are i i
remember them
um they went through the companies
and found that people who were on this
site who were willing to cheat on their
spouse
had more ethics violations had more
business issues had more
uh had less profits etc why this was
huge was
it had always been known you just need
to get the best baseball player drug
addict cheats on his wife all the time
it's fine because he shows up and
performs on that field
and or get this best ceo does it matter
their ethics they can have a drug
problems crazy stuff have private jets
that fly to islands whatever because
they're going to show up and they're
going to produce they're going to do
great and what this study showed
was that if somebody's willing to cheat
on their spouse
they're going to cheat in their business
if somebody's going to cut corners in
their personal life they're going to cut
corners in their business because that's
who they are that's the way they operate
in the world
and so
i tell you that to tell you if there's
decision making happening in somebody's
personal life that's like what are you
doing
i wouldn't trust you with my child then
i'm not going to trust you with my
business
the other side of that is this
at the company i work for um
they give us all debit cards
debit cards not credit cards they give
us debit cards
and one of my favorite things about my
boss um
his business buddies are like i can't
believe you would trust your employees
with debit cards to the company account
and his response is i can't believe you
would hire people to run your business
that have your family's name attached to
it
that you don't trust enough with your
money if you're going to trust them with
your name tr you see what i'm see where
i'm going here there is no difference
between business and and personal when
it comes to
i trust you here but not here
i just feel bad because he quit his job
to come out here and work for us so
that's why i feel guilty too
and so
now this becomes about you trying to
um squash how you feel
squash your values squash what's
important to you
because somebody else is going to feel
bad
the the non-technical term is you're a
people pleaser you're a peacemaker
and peacemakers often go to other people
to ask for how they should feel about
things
yeah like their parents even though
they've been married for five years like
their
spouse even though they're disgusted and
they feel not right and not level okay
see what i'm saying
yeah
and i want to make real clear
give me a couple of examples of other
behaviors that make you just say no no
no no no no i don't want this person in
my house
so
[Music]
he used to call the cops
on my husband and
make up that he was beating him to try
to get his dad in trouble because he
wouldn't let him go like out with his
friends and stuff like that okay
so you've got integrity issues and
you've got wisdom issues right
yeah yeah is there um substance abuse
issues as well
uh no
i would challenge that
stone's tone stone sober
as far as i know
i i
i said earlier i'm i don't get shocked
by much i would be shocked by that
here's the deal so you've got this
outside of the bell curve situation
right
um
yeah you've got somebody in your life
that's doing life differently than your
set of values the first thing you got to
do is you got to sit down and identify
what your values are
what's the life you want to live what's
the life you want to
lead um
you cannot change other people's
behavior
so your internet poll was right
like
the people gonna do what they're gonna
do right and i'm all about letting
people do what they want to do
um
the only person i can control is me and
the only person you can control bridget
is you
so i
at some point you got to say here's what
i'm going to tolerate in my life and
here's what i'm not here's what i'm
going to share meals with and here's
what i'm not
um
and the people that i've had at my house
at my house stay at my home
um
across the spectrum would would shock
people i love having people at my house
i like my kids meeting a wild array of
wonderful different people
my life is enriched by that
um
but one common thread through all the
people that stay at my home all the
people i consider friends all people i
consider people that i love has very
little to do with political spectrum has
very little to do with um
whether i agree with all their behaviors
or not
has way more to do with do i trust them
are they wise are they loving people who
care about me and my family and others
and um
that's not the situation you find
yourself in it sounds like you find
yourself in a situation where you feel
scared and exposed and your eyes just
bug out of your head and you're looking
around saying is it everyone else seeing
this
and
everyone's kind of just putting their
head down and saying let's just keep
going let's just keep going and at some
point you gotta look in the mirror and
say i'm cool with this i'm good this is
gonna be what this is gonna be i married
this guy i'm in and so if he's cool i'm
cool
or you're gonna look in the mirror and
say i'm gonna draw a line and say no
and i'd rather choose guilt over
resentment i'd rather feel guilty that i
tell this young man hey either you gotta
make some major life changes so we can
trust you and your wisdom
and your character or
um you're gonna have to go
you're gonna have to go and you're gonna
feel guilty about it you can feel bad
about it but doesn't mean it's the wrong
thing either that or you're gonna just
live with this behavior over and over
and over and over and over again and by
the way the behavior i'm talking about
is not about him having sex with his
brother and his brother's wife
that's disturbing in its own little
world i'm saying behavior things that
violate your moral compass and violate
your values you're gonna have to at some
point say
this is the line i draw
and um you might not be able to get rid
of them but you might say i'm gonna
choose to walk thank you very much it's
a choice you gotta make
um
and i wouldn't lose a lot of sleep and i
would stop calling my mom and i would
get one or two close friends of mine
who around my age maybe a little bit
older with some wisdom and sit down and
say okay i've got some hard decisions to
make here's what comes next